I love seeing women artists supporting
other women artists why was it important
for you to be here tonight and show up
Riccardi honestly I just thought it
would be a lot of fun a lot of time
events aren't and the kind of old
business so you don't really see any of
your friends and mine were coming here
so I thought I'd probably be like a real
party that was you know that my family
was hit by the fires I know that your
house came very close to being hit by
the fires how are you doing how's the
community doing oh I live in the Oaks
and we were very lucky everybody's house
is still standing this so I'm feeling
very thankful to have a home to go home
to so many of my friends don't so I'm
just very grateful that my house is
still still oh good yeah it's very close
I know you're working on new music is
that right what's going on do you feel
empowered in a way I know that you left
your label and fresh new beginning yeah
I left my label I announced it like two
weeks ago and then I signed a new deal
so I'm gonna announce that probably next
week yeah I'm really excited yeah
keeping secrets I can't wait to announce
everything and kind of like let
everybody know my plans for music but um
I'm going I'm I'm actually moving to
Atlanta in two weeks
yes so I'm gonna go and start recording
there and finish my album and
really good lots of new stuff happening
what prompted to move to Atlanta oh I
used to live there a long time ago maybe
ten years ago now so it's just good to
get back and see old people and get new
energy new things I know that your
friend Demi Lovato is out looking happy
and healthy have you good I haven't
heard from her but I've been watching
Oprah's old friends to all friends Stoke
their friends on social media um and she
looks great
it's very good to see her back
[Music]